[Musik]
es ist einer der schlechtesten bezahlten
beruf mit unmöglichen arbeitsbedingungen
ein sehr anstrengender beruf ein
typischer frauenberuf frauen die oftmals
keine anerkennung bekommen weil sie
keine wertschätzung dafür bekommen dass
sie den dreck der andern weg machen
in der schweiz sind die meisten über
55-jährigen putzfrauen portugiesinnen
ohne ausbildung oder papiere war dieser
job damals die einzig mögliche
beschäftigung
für einen lächerlichen lohn haben sie
ihr ganzes leben in der schweiz gekehrt
geschrubbt und gefegt
und wenn es um den ruhestand geht wird
klar dass ihre renten nicht reichen wird
um hier zu leben
[Musik]
zurück in ihr heimatland das wissen sie
das wäre die bestmögliche lösung
es ist aber schwieriger als man denkt
[Musik]
manuela machen sie den beruf als kurz
raus und lange 24 jahre seit 24 jahren
bin ich haus warten in diesem gebäude
und es gefällt mir
es ist nicht super die leute sind
zufrieden und es ist sauber
ach du bist ja es ist rutschig
guten morgen respektieren die leute ihre
arbeit
einige schon ja einige erkennen meine
arbeit an von ihnen erhalte ich ende
jahr schöne geschenke andere nicht wie
sehen meine arbeit gar nicht
verschmutzen die scheiben werfen papier
auf den boden und lassen es lieben
anstatt es in den müll zu werfen ohne
respekt wenn ich sie nicht grüßen mich
nicht macht ihnen das etwas aus ja klar
ich bin schließlich auch jemand wie
schäme mich nicht für meine arbeit aber
gewisse meinen sie seien was besseres
[Musik]
es ist ein gewöhnlicher montag in einem
gewöhnlichen leben der mit putzen
verbracht wurde zuerst bei privaten
jetzt in diesen genfer gebäuden manuela
56 jährige portugiesische putzfrau wie
viele aus ihrer generation
es ist mir schon bewusst dass sich viele
leute schämen aber ich nicht ich habe
nie ein geheimnis aus meinem beruf
gemacht nie gesagt dass ich in einem
büro im korb oder in der migros arbeiten
würde
co2 ist putzfrau
[Musik]
euro von einem zum anderen zu rennen die
früher war ermüdend
zu hause angekommen hatte ich meine
familie meine arbeit zu hause
das war ebenfalls erhöht jetzt ist es
anders
jetzt habe ich nur noch 22 arbeitgeber
ja und da fühle ich mich wohl ich stehe
morgens auf und freue mich auf meine
arbeit ich beklage mich nicht im
gegensatz zu anderen das kann ich nicht
ich habe glück und hoffe dass es bis zu
meiner pensionierung weiter so verläuft
und ich meine arbeit behalten kann
manuela hätte niemals gedacht sich
sorgen um ihre rente machen zu müssen
als sie in eines der reichsten länder
europas einwanderte das war vor 36
jahren mit 20 ist sie aus portugal in
die schweiz gekommen
zu ihrem mann der als maler arbeitete
und sich damals schon in genf
niedergelassen hatte in den 80er jahren
brauchte man billige arbeitskräfte
deshalb sind viele portugiesen in die
schweiz ausgewandert
[Musik]
erinnern sie sich an den tag ihrer
abreise ja sogar daran wie ich angezogen
war
wollen sie es unter 10
ich trug eine dunkelblaue latzhose und
ein hemd mit roten blümchen hat mein
land zu verlassen und meine schwester
ich sehr lieb hatte sie war meine zweite
mama aber ja ich kam mit meinem mann
zusammenzuleben
[Musik]
das ist meine puderdose welche mich seit
jahren während meiner ferien begleitet
eine tochter schreibt mir jeweils was
rein
ich liebe dich mama schöne ferien du
bist mir fehlen aber diesmal zeichnete
sie ein herzchen
ich liebe meine tochter manuela lebt
alleine in dieser wohnung von der firma
welche sie sich nur dank des hausrats
jobs leisten kann
wie viele portugiesinnen hätte sie
niemals gedacht so lange in der schweiz
zu bleiben
ich dachte erst mal her zu kommen um
dann doch eines tages wieder zu hause in
portugal zu leben
wir stellten uns vor dass wir
zurückgehen würden bevor die kinder
eingeschult werden sie sind doch hier
zur schule und ich bin geblieben und bin
immer noch hier
wie manuela sind viele der emigrierten
portugiesinnen aus den 80ern geblieben
heute machen sie zwölf prozent der
schweizer bevölkerung aus
[Musik]
freitagabend in genf ein mini portugal
inmitten der industriezone
[Musik]
die portugiesische community ist eine
der integrierten in der schweiz und
gleichzeitig bleibt sie ihrer kultur und
folklore treu alleine in genf gibt es
circa 40 solcher gemeinschaften
jeden freitag nach ihrer arbeits woche
verbringt maria hier wo sie ihr land
welches sie verlassen hat und die
tradition vom familienclan die bei den
portugiesen besonders stark ist wieder
findet
[Musik]
rang
man fühlt sich ein wenig wie zu hause
wir geben diese tradition von generation
zu generation weiter meine großeltern
waren auch schon teil davon
leider kann ich sie nicht mit ihnen aber
dafür mit meiner mama teilen wie ist das
singen zu sehen ich glaube das erlaubt
die ein wenig auszubrechen und nicht so
viel an ihrer arbeit zu denken ich freue
mich für sie
und jetzt gehen sie tanzen ich ja
normalerweise singe ich aber ich werde
versuchen ein bisschen zu tanzen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
maria hat sich in der schweiz ein leben
aufgebaut familie hobbys arbeit die
schweiz ist zu ihrem land geworden
am anfang war das nicht einfach im
flugzeug sagte mir mein mann du wirst
sehen wie schön es in genf ist es gibt
einen see um das wasser zu sehen gehe
ich an den strand habe ich geantwortet
es war sehr hart am anfang hatte ich
noch keine arbeit er ging arbeiten und
ich fühlte mich sehr allein die
einsamkeit ist nicht gut wenn mein mann
arbeiten ging stand ich am fenster
schaut auf die berge machte wie weit weg
portugal ist und habe angefangen zu
weinen
mein mann mir meinen pass versteckt weil
ich ihm gesagt habe du wirst schon sehen
eines tages wenn du nach hause kommst
bin ich weg maria ist geblieben
30 jahre sind es jetzt schon seit 30
jahren steht sie früh morgens auf und
kommt spät abends nach hause um in
firmen zu putzen
maria hat nie bei privaten geputzt sie
hat immer eine offiziell deklarierte
stelle verlangt und ist bei einer
putzfirma für zwei stunden pro tag und
20 franken die stunde angestellt ich
habe im vornherein gewusst dass ich als
putzfrau arbeiten würde weil es meinen
in portugal ausgeübten beruf hier nicht
gibt
ich hatte in einer fabrik die
trainingsanzüge herstellt gearbeitet
hier gibt's das nicht ich mache das gern
aber es ist nicht immer gut genug
bezahlt wenn ich einen rechten lohn
bekommen mache ich diese arbeit gerne
contra jedem vor
wenn an einer meiner arbeitsstellen
waren noch andere frauen anderer
nationalitäten und sie kamen zu mir und
sagten portugiesinnen sind wie gemacht
fürs putzen
zum glück können wir das gut habe ich
geantwortet putzen ist ein beruf wie
jeder andere auch aber eben kein
kommunist bei es können ja nicht alle
professoren oder ärzte seien es braucht
alles in der gesellschaft man stelle
sich mal vor es gäbe keine putzfrau
[Musik]
ich putze nur zwei stunden 1 und
verdiene 700 franken im monat nicht mehr
weil wir pro stunde
19 franken 85 nach allen abzügen bleiben
noch 15 franken pro stunde
mehr nicht
[Musik]
normalerweise bei einem acht stunden tag
könnte man ungefähr 4000 franken
verdienen aber heutzutage vergibt kein
arbeitgeber acht stunden putzarbeit an
die gleiche person
wir rennen von hier nach da quer durch
genf um vier oder fünf stunden für
mehrere arbeitgebern zu arbeiten aber
niemals acht stunden für ein und
denselben arbeitgeber die putzfrauen wie
in einer reinigungsfirma angestellt sind
kommen nicht auf acht stunden arbeit pro
tag weil die arbeitgeber von
gesetzlichen schlupflöchern profitieren
um anspruch auf pensionskassengelder zu
haben muss mindestens 21 1300 franken
pro jahr
beim selben arbeitgeber verdient werden
mit zwei stunden pro woche für je 19
franken 85 ist maria weit davon entfernt
anrecht auf ihre zweite säule zu haben
wie ihre rente kann sie nur mit ihren
eigenen einzahlungen und ihrer hv
rechnen
wissen sie wie hoch ihre rente sein wird
ich denke kaum mehr als tausend franken
um hoffnung zu haben wenigstens 1000
franken rente zu erhalten muss maria 700
franken mit einem nebenjob verdienen
seit 24 jahren steht sie jeden tag um 5
uhr auf um die bestellungen der hefte
für die kioske in der romandie
vorzubereiten
die portugiesische migrationswelle der
80er jahre brachte also günstige
arbeitskräfte die nicht nur wenig
kosteten sondern oftmals auch schwarz
arbeiteten
zumindest in den anfängen
[Musik]
das ist isabel sie ist alleine in die
schweiz gekommen
sie war nie verheiratet und hat auch
keine kinder
sie war auf der suche nach einem
besseren leben
links als ich mit meinem kopf und am
bahnhof ankam hatte ich große angst weil
ich an der grenze gefragt wurde was ich
in der schweiz machen wolle antwortete
dass ich urlaub bei freunden mache
darauf konnte ich die grenze problemlos
passieren
aber ja ich hatte angst wenn man mich
nicht durchgelassen hätte was wäre mir
anderes übrig geblieben als wieder in
meine heimat zurückzugehen
isabell ist in den 60er jahren im norden
von portugal in einem kleinen dorf in
der nähe von porto geboren
ein von sala saß diktatur und abneigung
gegen die bildung geschwächtes und
verarmen des portugal
[Musik]
zu der zeit konnte eine von dreien weder
lesen noch schreiben
erst 1964 wurden die schulen für alle
obligatorisch und das auch nur für zehn
jahre ein schweres erbe des
analphabetismus daher die vielzahl der
frauen in haushalts berufen
[Musik]
die schule begann bei uns mit sechs
jahren und dauerte vier obligatorische
jahre bis 10
diejenigen welche die möglichkeit hatten
besuchten weitere schule finanziell die
möglichkeit hatten die anderen eben
nicht ohne ausbildung arbeit und ohne
familie ist das exil die einzige
perspektive für ein besseres leben
nach einem zwischenstopp in frankreich
kommt isabel 1992 mit 32 jahren in die
schweiz
das ist das erste foto als ich in genf
ankam
ich ging mit einer freundin spazieren
wie finden sie sich in genf hat isabell
keine wahl
die einzige unmittelbar verfügbare
arbeit die sie schwarz verrechnen kann
ist bei privaten zu putzen
so entsteht ein höllischer rhythmus zu
diensten anderer und so vergisst sie ihr
eigenes leben
es war sehr hart ich begann morgens um
halb sieben und arbeitete bis 21 30 22
uhr abends ohne eine freie minute
ich hatte keine eigene wohnung
und da ich keine papiere hatte musste
ich diese arbeiten annehmen
so konnte ich wohnen und essen 28 jahre
später isabel hat mittlerweile den c
ausweis mit 60 jahren übersteigt der
brutto monatsgehalt keine 3200 franken
ich kann nicht viel unternehmen zum
beispiel ins kino oder in einem
restaurant essen gegen wenn ich vor
einem restaurant stehe und nicht
reingehen kann aber andere schon fühle
ich mich ein wenig minderwertig aber ich
kann es mir einfach nicht leisten
ich muss mich damit abfinden ich habe
keine wahl
[Musik]
wie viele arbeitgeber haben sie im
moment ich habe einen 23 56 78
nicht alle am gleichen ort
dadurch verliere ich viel zeit mit rom
fahren
an gewissen tagen bin ich am abend sehr
müde
das alles für 3200 franken pro monat
selbst mit einer zweiten säule wenn man
sich isabell rente nicht vorstellen
auch sie nicht mit 60 jahren hat sie
keine anfragen für eine rentenberechnung
gestellt auch keine zukunftspläne
gemacht
[Musik]
nicht wie immer alles kaputt machen
nein das tun sie ja gar nicht alles gut
sie provoziere mich gerne
selbstverständlich und sie spielen gerne
mit
sicher kennt und sie auch schon 20 jahre
stimmt wir zählen sie ja von allen
arbeitgebern ist louis keller ihr am
liebsten er hat sie oft unterstützt und
er war es der sie regelmäßig auf ihre
rente hingewiesen hat ab und zu denke
ich an meiner pensionierung aber nicht
wirklich
ich verdränge es ich weiß ja nicht wie
es dann sein wird
verdrängen es nicht gut man muss sich
damit beschäftigen
ja ich weiß dass ich rechnen und planen
muss
sie werden eine kleine rente haben und
keine großen ersparnisse das leben in
der schweiz ist teuer
ich werde es mir nicht erlauben können
mit 64 aufhören zu arbeiten
darum geht es nicht
sie müssen einfach daran denken dass sie
eine kleine rente hatten und keine große
ersparnisse
[Musik]
die frage mich schon wie man lieben nach
der pensionierung sein wird es ist nicht
einfach für eine alleinstehende person
manchmal versuche ich zu vergessen aber
es beschäftigt mich
sie denken nicht gerne daran ja genau
wie viel denken sie werden sie erhalten
ungefähr 1000 franken
wenn überhaupt weil hier sind die renten
wenn man nicht viel eingezahlt hat gibt
es nicht viel und ich habe nur 20
24 jahre beiträge eingezahlt aber mit
1000 franken ist es um möglichen geld zu
lieben
[Musik]
ich würde gerne nach portugal
zurückkehren
da könnte ich eventuell das haus
renovieren
also den anteil meiner brüder und
schwestern abkaufen
und dann das ganze haus renovieren wir
haben land nebenan somit könnte ich
meinen kleinen gemüsegarten
bewirtschaften
kleine tiere wie kaninchen und hühner
haben
so bin ich aufgewachsen
ich liebe dieses leben isabell ist seit
fünf jahren nicht mehr in das
familienhaus zurückgekehrt wir schlagen
ihr vor sie nach portugal zu begleiten
um einen rentenbezug von dort aus zu
prüfen
vorgesehene abreise ist in drei tagen
ich bin der schweiz dankbar sie hat mir
viel gegeben
aber hier unter diesen schwierigen
umständen zu leben
nein ich bevorzuge es nach hause zu
gehen
ihr zuhause ist in diesem haus in london
in portugal
das paar musste zwei kredite für den
kauf des bodens und die finanzierung der
arbeiten aufnehmen
die rückkehr ist also nicht per sofort
es ist noch nicht fertig renoviert weil
der von uns beauftragte baumeister das
geld behalten hat und wir dadurch 20.000
euro verloren haben diesen betrag müssen
wir nun der bank zurück sein
wir sind gezwungen die arbeiten selber
fertig zu machen wäre für mich ist es
das lebenswerk meine eltern ihres ganzen
lebens
naja ihres ganzen lebens das ist
wirklich ein großes opfer ich will diese
arbeiten fertig machen um noch zu
erleben wie meine eltern darin wohnen
bis jetzt konnten sie nicht einen tag
und keine einzige nacht darin verbringen
paula musste in ihrer kindheit opfer
erbringen den bruder betreuen sich um
die wäsche kümmern damit ihre mutter
arbeiten konnte paula ist immer davon
ausgegangen dass ihre eltern einen
angenehmen und sorglosen ruhestand
genießen werden
aber wenn sie heute ihre ängste sieht
wird er die dramatische situation
bewusst ich hörte immer wieder sagen
dass mit der zeit immer weniger geld in
den kassen sei weil es später weniger
löhne geben wird mir war aber nicht
bewusst dass man von der rente nicht
leben kann in nordhalben ihre lehrer sie
darauf angesprochen
ja sie haben uns erklärt in jungen
jahren zu sparen an die zukunft zu
denken
und uns frühzeitig darauf vorzubereiten
obwohl die pensionierung noch in weiter
ferne ist macht das angst mit 27 schon
an die pensionierung zu denken
ja das macht schon ein wenig angst im
moment habe ich lust an meine karriere
an eine familie und kinder zu denken und
nicht an etwas was so viel später im
leben sein wird aber die pensionierung
beschäftigt mich schon und das hat etwas
bedrückendes ich dachte immer dass die
rente für alle 1700 franken betragen
würde
aber nein maßgebend sind die
beitragsjahre und wie viele jahre man
gearbeitet
wenn die beiträge nicht regelmäßig
während 40 jahren einbezahlt werden hat
man keine volle rente zu gute komplett
wie viele andere kommt maria nicht klar
mit dem system der pensionierung
um eine komplette rente zu erhalten von
2370 franken müssen beiträge ab
zwanzigjährig ohne unterbruch bis 64 bzw
65 einbezahlt werden und man muss einen
jahreslohn von 85.000 franken verdienen
in anderen worten sehr wenige leute
schaffen das
[Musik]
hallo mein zu uns wie geht's arbeiten
halt das ist kalt geworden wenn die
altersvorsorge bei den schweizerinnen
thema nummer eins ist dann ist sie es
genauso bei den eingewanderten familien
mit der ganzen komplexität der
zerrissenheit und rückkehr in irland
manuela ist sich dessen bewusst und
sucht mit ihren kindern jetzt schon nach
möglichst schmerzfreien lösungen eine
woche komme ich dann jeweils zu dir und
eine gehe ich zu deiner schwester
geteilten hätte dienst genau eine
aufteilung eine woche bei mir und zwei
wochen bei mietern nicht eine und ein 1
1 monat und ein monat ein monat ist zu
lang wir werden sie wir haben noch zeit
wie ihr seht nehmen wir das thema mit
humor
aber klar wenn wir später entscheidungen
treffen müssen werden wir für sie da
sein und helfen
aus diesem grund erlaube ich mir zu
scherzen 2 bei mika und eine bei mir
egal was sie entscheidet wir werden für
sie da sein
bis anhin war sie immer für uns da
sie hat uns immer geholfen ich komme
jeden mittag helfer wie ich kann aber
wir werden auf jeden fall da sein
[Musik]
hallo meine tochter sunny
seinerzeit wollte sie nach portugal
zurück aber wie ich sie kenne wäre sie
glücklicher hier aber sie sagt es sei
schwieriger mit ihrer band
wir werden versuchen ihm zu helfen ich
denke sie wäre hier glücklicher als dort
ihre schwestern und brüder nie wieder
dorthin sind fühlen sich etwas einsam
und verbittert
ja bestimmt wäre sie glücklicher hier
mit ihren kindern und grosskinder april
wie auch immer sie sich entscheiden wird
wir unterstützen sie aber da ich denke
dass sie hier glücklicher wäre helfe ich
ihr gerne wenn ich kann sich hier
zurechtzufinden
wir werden sehen
auch die keine sorgen
[Musik]
gute war meine liebe sehr schön danke
mein herz und ich wollte mich eben mit
der unterstützung meiner kinder dachte
ich meine zweite säule zu beziehen nach
portugal zu gehen um dort etwas zu
kaufen weil hier weiß ich nicht wie hoch
meine rente sein wird das macht mir
angst
in dieser wohnung kann ich nicht bleiben
ich würde mich nicht aufdrängen bei
meinen kinder zu wohnen
aber meine tochter sagt mama was willst
du in portugal machen alleine wenn mein
bruder und ich dir helfen kannst du
hierbleiben
ich weiß es nicht
die zukunft wird es zeigen ja ich denke
viel daran aber ich will ebenfalls dass
meine kinder zufrieden sind
ich kann mir kaum vorstellen weg zu
gehen und sie zurück zu lassen
mit meiner rente werde ich aber nicht
die möglichkeit haben hierzubleiben
die kinder werden ihr eigenes leben
führen und selbst kinder haben das nagt
an mir
[Musik]
wird manuela weg gehen müssen
seit 2010 ist die einwanderung der
portugiesen rückgängig es gibt mehr
vorteile für die portugiesen die
wegziehen als für diejenigen die in die
schweiz kommen der wirtschaft in
portugal geht es besser und das
rentnerleben in der schweiz ist viel zu
teuer das ist auch der fall von
tageseltern tiago ist als neunjähriger
in die schweiz gekommen
er ist vollkommen voix hauswart im
universitätsspital in lausanne
verheiratet mit einer portugiesin zwei
kinder
seine eltern sind vor knapp sechs
monaten zurückgekehrt
hallo wie geht's gut und dir
und wie geht's papa das geht ihm gut er
ist draußen im garten lassen ist nicht
schlimm
im haus alles gut ja was am strand am
wochenende ja was schön war schönes
wetter es ist so schön am strand und tut
so gut irgendwie uns morgen vielleicht
heute abend oder heute abend um mit den
kleinen zu sprechen
ok ciao ciao kästchen schönen nachmittag
telefoniert er öfters eigentlich jeden
mittag während des mittagessens
ist das euer kleines ritual
ja das ist schön ihre eltern möchten
nicht darauf verzichten
ich denke das wäre hart es ist schon
hart genug weg zu sein
so können wir uns wenigstens sehen es
ist als seien sie hier ohne wirklich
hier zu sein
das macht es erträglicher
[Musik]
meine eltern sind schon weg diesen
sommer werden meine schwiegereltern
gehen und wir beide bleiben dann alleine
hier ohne unsere eltern
[Musik]
wir fragen uns ob wir gehen oder bleiben
sollen um diesen endlosen teufelskreis
zu unterbrechen
meine eltern haben ihre eltern verlassen
um mit ihren kindern hierher zu kommen
jetzt gehen sie und ich bleibe mit
meinen kindern wenn ich bis zu meiner
pensionierung bleibe und dann gehe
werden meine kinder hier bleiben und so
weiter man fragt sich was das soll
ein teufelskreis der zerrissenheit
aufhalten eine frage die in der
gemeinschaft omnipräsent ist in marias
familie dreht sich alles um die
pensionierung jose louis wird in zwei
jahren pensioniert aber sogar für ihn
als maurer und einem verdienst von 6000
franken wird es schwierig sein
pappas rente beträgt 2.000 etwas von du
noch mit 50 prozent und ich verdiene
2000 etwas mit 4000 kannst du hier leben
nein ich denke nicht
also mit 65 gehe ich nach portugal ich
bleibe nicht hier
philipp wird wahrscheinlich bleiben
paula weiß ich nicht vielleicht
ich habe nur das gekannt ich werde
bleiben ja ich bin hier groß geworden
ich liebe die stadt in portugal leben
wir eher auf dem land im moment ist es
noch zu früh um an meine pensionierung
zu denken ich habe ja erst angefangen
[Musik]
macht es dir etwas aus das wir gehen
ich denke es ist besser für sie denn
hier wird es kompliziert sein kumpel
aber es macht mir schon zu schaffen
uns gefällt es trotz allem gut hier
wir fühlen uns wohl wir wurden in diesem
land empfangen haben eine gute
ausbildung und gute arbeit zb meinem
papa gefällt es sehr gut hier die
vorstellung weg gehen zu müssen und
seine pensionierung nicht hier genießen
zu können weil man nicht für sich
aufkommen kann ist schon irgendwie
traurig er hat seine freunde und
beschäftigung hier ist ebenfalls
mitglied verschiedener vereine auf all
das müsste er verzichten
[Musik]
zum zeitpunkt der pensionierung ist eine
portugiesische familie mit einem zweiten
exil konfrontiert
[Musik]
in der einsamkeit ihrer wohnung ist der
große tag für isabell bekommen
mit 60 jahren bleibt nicht mehr viel
zeit
sie muss demnächst eine rückkehr in ihre
heimat ins auge fassen
[Musik]
ich freue mich in meine heimat
zurückzukehren mein haus wieder zu sehen
das ist ein großer moment für mich und
bedeutet mir viel
was erwarten sie wenn sie in dieses haus
gehen
das ist schwer zu sagen ich habe keine
familie mehr dort ich finde schön mein
haus wo ich mit meiner mutter und tante
gelebt hatte wieder zu sehen
[Musik]
was erhoffen sie sich davon
wenn ich die möglichkeit hätte das haus
zu renovieren würde ich gerne meine
verbleibende zeit in meiner heimat
verbringen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo guten tag die geht's ich falle
immer wieder hin und wie läuft's
isabelles seit dem tod ihrer mutter
nicht zurückgekommen
das haus wurde seitdem nie wieder
betreten nichts hat sich verändert
[Musik]
das ist das zimmer meiner mutter da habe
ich mit ihr geschlafen im selben bett ja
winter war es kalt
das haus hatte keine heizung und um uns
gegenseitig warm zu halten haben wir im
gleichen bett geschlafen
es ist februar
es ist sehr feuchtem haus es herrscht
ein modriger geruch alles ist sehr
schnell herunter gekommen
[Musik]
es ist traurig ich bin traurig dass
hausen diesen zustand wieder zu sehen
es war zerfallen wenn nichts gemacht
wird das ist klar aber das blendet mich
das hatten sie nicht erwartet
ein wenig schon aber nicht in diesem
ausmaß sind jetzt mehr als zehn jahre
seit es nicht mehr bewohnt ist zerfällt
mehr und mehr
die mauern sind beschädigt das ist
feucht unmöglich in diesem zustand darin
zu leben
in anbetracht ihrer finanziellen
situation in der schweiz und im haus
hier denken sie dass ich ihr traum
nichts auflöst im moment habe ich nicht
die möglichkeit das haus zu renovieren
und nun ich werde nicht herkommen
[Musik]
am andern ende von portugal bei lissabon
haben die eltern von tiago mehr glück
aber ob das wirklich glück ist
[Musik]
die farbe ist noch frisch der garten in
arbeit
junge pensionierte in ihrem haus gekauft
von ihrer zweiten säule antonio und
paula bauen sich ein neues leben auf
ganz alleine
wir haben zimmer für die kinder bereit
gestellt sogar mit badezimmer damit sie
uns besuchen und sich wohlfühlen können
es ist wichtig dass alle ihr eigenes
zimmer haben
[Musik]
hallo hallo wie geht's gut und die
bestens du papa auch guten tag mein
lieber und läuft mit der arbeit
na ja es geht papa arbeitet im garten
streicht die außenmauer an arbeit fehlt
es ihm nicht ist doch gut so bleibt er
dran man muss sich beschäftigen
ich hatte noch keine zeit die papiere
der kranken oder sicherung zu schicken
hast du sie noch nicht geschickt nein
hatte keine zeit
das hast du dringend machen ich habe die
zahlungsaufforderung bereits passiert
ist alles blockiert in diesem neuen
leben kommt ein unnötiger
administrativer stress dazu die
portugiesische regierung verkündet das
ende der zehnjährigen steuerbefreiung
für die ausländischen oder für die ins
land zurückgekehrten rentner
zum glück sind sie nicht davon betroffen
ihre sorge betrifft die
krankenversicherung die schweiz verlangt
die begleichung der rechnungen
obschon sie bereits seit sechs monaten
in portugal versichert sind
ich bin etwas verloren sie verpflichten
mich und meinen mann die summe von 1000
franken zu bezahlen
1000 franken das stresst mich wenn ich
nicht bezahlen werden sie mich betreiben
und ich werde gebüßt
[Musik]
mein sohn hat angerufen er spricht
besser französisch 40 er hat alles
erklärt sie sich in portugal verhält
er sagte mir die schweizer das
komplizierteste land wir sind hier weit
entfernt von einer idealen pensionierung
schon nach sechs monaten kommt
langeweile auf
paula taucht in ihre erinnerungen ein
denkt an die zeit vor der pensionierung
und an die zeit in der kinderkrippe
voller leben als sie als putzfrau
arbeitete haben sie lange in dieser
krippe gearbeitet
14 jahre ich habe sehr gute erinnerungen
sie waren sehr zufrieden mit meiner
arbeit diese de contraire wert nur sich
daran zu erinnern tut gut
sie waren ja doch ein paar jährchen
ich erinnere mich wie sie immer sagten
das sei voller energie und fleißig und
jetzt das kann ich hier schon machen ich
habe nichts zu tun
mein mann arbeitet ein wenig in daten
und ich nicht langweile mich schon ein
bisschen fühlen sie sich etwas verloren
ja genau ein wenig verloren so fühle ich
mich
[Musik]
ich habe weder freunde noch freundinnen
her ich kenne ja niemanden
[Musik]
ich fühle mich als einwanderin zuerst
bin ich in die schweiz ausgewandert und
jetzt bin ich nach portugal ausgewandert
wenn ich meinen sohn anrufe reden wir
darüber dass ich mich einsam fühle hier
[Musik]
aus reflex spricht man französisch man
sagt bordeaux oder fragt etwas
und anstatt eur zusagen sagt man franken
manchmal habe ich angst dass die leute
denken ich sei schweizerin
wir trinken heute nachmittag gehen
während den strand bei uns liegt schnee
zeigt wie von den chinesen shao den
schnee schnee schnee fehlt uns trotz
dieser idyllischen landschaft vermisst
pauler den schnee und die schweizer
berge dazu kommt das gefühl ungerecht
behandelt zu werden von einem land das
nicht imstande ist ihnen eine
ordentliche rente anzubieten
sowohl den portugiesinnen als auch den
schweizerinnen
[Musik]
und wie fühlen sie sich hier im kopf bin
ich noch in der schweiz 95 prozent
meiner freunde und freundinnen sind dort
das ist normal ich hatte da viele
kontakte
sie fehlen aber so ist das leben in der
schweiz war ich ein glücklicher mensch
nun geht es darum auch hier weiterhin
glücklich zu sein ist keiner glücklich
sie wird sich daran gewöhnen
sie braucht noch ein ja gut ich lebe
besser aber es gibt eben immer ein aber
die
[Musik]